boa tarde
nunca conheci quem tivesse levado
porrada
todos os meus conhecidos têm sido
campeões em tudo
assim fernando pessoa abre um dos seus
poemas mais conhecidos cujo nome poema
em linha reta até hoje consideram que a
nossa sociedade encara assim a educação
numa linha reta
pra mim a educação do século 21
mudou o que precisa mudar muito mais
ela precisa ser encarada como uma linha
circular na educação do século 21
empatia coragem e vulnerabilidade devem
despertar a autonomia ea liberdade
a grande questão é como fazer isso
trabalhar em grupo saber lidar com
conflitos ter pensamento crítico são
alguns dos valores que escola e
universidade precisam estar mais atentos
carrego comigo uma experiência de 16
anos em sala de aula e mais dois anos e
meio no ensino a distância e posso
afirmar categoricamente que a escola
além de ensinar as matérias cognitivas
como física química matemática e
português
eu sou professor de português e redação
ela também precisa trabalhar com as
habilidades não cognitivas ou que nós
costumamos chamar de esqui os ford f
future
a escola precisa mudar
e nesse papel de mudança a gente vê que
os professores são muito responsáveis
por essa mudança
mas a grande responsabilidade em
capacitar os alunos
do jeito que está as coisas não podem
continuar nessa imagem que a gente
observa
acredito que muita gente ainda encara a
escola hoje com essa imagem na escola
fria repulsiva
afastar da chata
eu convido na verdade todo mundo pensar
que precisamos passar por uma estrutura
de transformação e essa estrutura de
transformação precisa entender que o
aluno precisa sair da categoria de aluno
e virar estudante eu defendo essa teoria
que o aluno é aquele que é passivo fica
sentado no fundo da sala recebendo as
informações enquanto o estudante que é
aquele que é ativo é o que pratica o que
estuda de fato isto da armação é um
verbo e estudar implica ter atitude
implica ter prazer em picape e gás a
estudar pode ser divertido estudar tem
que ser prazeroso
só que nesse momento a gente pára e
pensa em ter um responsável para essa
mudança
e antes que muito muitos pensem que a
responsabilidade seja do governo da
escola ou da universidade
essa responsabilidade é do professor até
porque o professor é o que mais está em
contato com esse aluno mas não seria um
tanto quanto injusto depositar essa
responsabilidade só para o professor o
que queremos da universidade até que
ponto as universidades de fato elas têm
encorajado os nossos professores até que
ponto universidades e escolas têm
trabalhado toda a questão da
criatividade para que nossos professores
formem melhores alunos
nesse sentido eu tento inverter então o
processo
devemos trabalhar dando autonomia e
liberdade para o aluno e é nesse momento
que eu convido essa platéia de hoje a
entender o que significam três palavras
às quais vêm estudando um bom tempo
a empatia a coragem ea vulnerabilidade
empatia é você se colocar no lugar do
outro
reconhecendo seus sentimentos e suas
perspectivas
coragem na etimologia da palavra
significa agir com o coração ea
vulnerabilidade é você ter apetite pelo
risco é o gostar de pensar grande é o se
entregar por inteiro
só que nessa tríade a gente precisa
reconhecer que a empatia é a base dela
ela é a mãe das outras virtudes
nesse sentido a gente precisa parar e
pensar será que o professor realmente
ele pode ser o único responsável por
isso
e nessas definições de empatia coragem
vulnerabilidade a gente volta o que a
gente está defendendo sobre a
transformação de aluno em estudante eu
posso afirmar porque eu fui aluno da
uerj eu fiz letras na universidade
estadual do rio de janeiro e as
universidades em alguns momentos em
natori um aluno tanto quanto passivo
eu tive uma primeira experiência que não
era assim que eu cheguei no primeiro
período da faculdade eu tive ótimos
mestres ótimos professores só posso
citar o nome de alguns aqui agora eu me
lembro
sérgio nazaré excelente professor de
cultura portuguesa
eu tive aula com a maria antonieta de
teoria da literatura eu fui aluno do
teste o lima professor de linguística
mais um professor em especial me chamou
sempre atenção e tocou a minha história
de vida já num primeiro momento da
faculdade porque primeiro dia de aula
que a gente conhece o professor gustavo
bernardo krause
ele passa pra turma um exercício vamos
analisar o conto de guimarães rosa a
terceira margem do rio
só que eu não vou explicar nada cada
aluno vai ter que entender o conto por
si só eu e os meus colegas na época
pensamos peraí
esse professor ele transfere a
responsabilidade dele
o aluno que naquele momento a época eu
pensei poxa que coisa injusta o
professor não faz o papel dele que te
ensinar
depois mais tarde ouvir entender
gustavo bernardo na verdade estava
desenvolvendo nos alunos autonomia
em liberdade ele pediu que a turma
entender se o que era o conto e aí sim
fizesse um trabalho montasse uma aula
para apresentar em sala
nesse momento eu queria fazer um
contraponto as três palavras empatia
coragem vulnerabilidade se pararmos para
pensar nos seus opostos empatia seria
indiferença a coragem seria a questão de
você está um tanto quanto inerte e
quando você fala em vulnerabilidade você
está um tanto quanto resguardado
eu poderia afirmar que a faculdade as
universidades elas se encontram muito
mais no 2º tri pé ea gente precisa saber
neste momento o que a gente faz para
mudar esse estado
o que a gente faz para transformar
alunos em estudante
e aí eu trouxe algumas histórias para te
contar que em alguns lugares esse tripé
já vencido desenvolvido já vem sendo
apresentada e tem dado certo
a primeira história que eu tenho para te
contar é de um estudo que fizeram na
faculdade de medicina da unicamp entre
um professor doutor chamado marcelo
sheron ele fez uma pesquisa tentando
provar a seguinte teoria há quem pense
que o médico é aquele que tem que ficar
mais distante do seu paciente para poder
tratar com mais imparcialidade cada
situação mas ele foi justamente uma
pesquisa pra defender que a empatia
ajuda em muito no tratamento de um
paciente
então ele fez um levantamento com alunos
universitários da unicamp de medicina em
500 alunos ele obteve um retorno em que
94 por cento deles disseram que houve o
paciente torna o tratamento um resultado
muito mais positivo
a empatia vale muito a pena
a segunda história que eu tenho para te
contar é sobre a patrícia amor
eu conheço essa história estudando o
assunto empatia patrícia amor é uma
designer em 1109 679
bur recém-formada 26 anos trabalha num
escritório muito famoso rimando lowe
pensando uma idéia eu quero criar uma
geladeira cuja a porta seja mais leve
por conta das pessoas que têm problemas
de artrite que ela leva essa ideia para
o escritório em que ela trabalhava
ela trabalhava com 350 homens era a
única mulher em companheiro dela vem e
fala olha aqui a gente não costuma
pensar nos clientes na hora de criar um
produto não ela fica furiosa
a partir dali a patrícia desenvolve uma
das maiores experiências simpáticas do
século 20
a bateria fez patrícia se travestiu de
uma senhora de 85 anos
para isso teve que colocar sobre o seu
corpo todas as intempéries de uma
senhora de idade colocou lá táxi sobre o
rosto pra aparecer mais em jogada passou
um produto na vista nos óculos de moda
não enxergar diz dinheiro de forma
completa 100% obstruiu de uma certa
forma audição para ouvir um pouco menos
colocou algumas bandagem sobre o torço
pra aparecer um pouco mais corcunda um
pouco mais cansada calçou os sapatos de
alturas desiguais para justamente ter
que usar uma bengala para compensar e
durante três anos de 1979 e 1982
patrícia visitou várias cidades da
américa do norte subiu a escada de metrô
andou por ônibus lotados empurrou portas
de departamentos pesadas e qual foi a
conclusão disso tudo
patrícia se tornou uma das maiores
designers do mundo no final do século 20
ela foi mais de uma das defensoras do
design que a gente chama de design
inclusivo do design universal é dela por
exemplo a autoria de você pensar em
descascador de batatas que tem aqueles
grossos cabos de borracha é delas
autoria
a conclusão a que chego é que freud no
século 19
dizia que o homem está fadado a história
influenciar pelo seu próprio ego
eu diria que na transição do século 20
para o século 21
a gente hoje vive uma outra era do homo
empáticos nós estamos saindo da
transição em que nós tínhamos aquele
pensamento cartesiano penso logo existo
para a frase ser você é logo sou obama
em 2008 fez um discurso nas vésperas da
sua campanha em que falava mais ou menos
assim fala-se que esse país apresenta
muito um déficit federal
eu prefiro pensar que a gente ainda está
na fase do déficit da empatia em que
precisamos pensar mais no lado do outro
e aí meus amigos só retorna a idéia de
que professores precisam ser estimulado
oris inspiradores no processo
educacional
eu já contei duas histórias para falar
da empatia mas agora eu te convido a
conhecer a minha história de vida pra
falar sobre empatia
eu tive um sonho um dia eu vou te contar
um belo dia eu tive um sonho em que
entrava em um consultório médico uma
senhorinha de idade
e essa senhorinha foi se consultar
comigo eu era o médico ela entrava no
consultório e me pedia doutor valadares
tinha o meu nome na porta do consultório
eduardo valladares
ela falava doutor valadares
eu tô com muitos problemas no coração só
pode me dar um remédio para poder
melhorar eu requisitava alguns exames
essa senhorinha passava alguns remédios
e dias depois essa senhorinha voltava ao
meu consultório para agradecer doutor
valadares muito obrigado só me ajudou
o senhor me curou
sim meus queridos um dia eu já quis
fazer medicina
um dia eu quis ser médico e foi estudar
um dos maiores cursinhos aqui no rio de
janeiro pré-vestibulares e depois de
duas tentativas depois de terminado o
ensino médio e duas tentativas no
vestibular
eu pude perceber que minha vida era
outra e como é que isso aconteceu
um belo dia que dia aconteceu uma
epifania um momento revelador
estava eu sentado assistindo a uma aula
de redação de um professor magnífico e
no meio de uma sala de aula para ser uma
luz como essa de seu naquela hora diz
eduardo estava lá
é você naquele dia eu decidi ser
professor
a partir daquele dia eu mudei a minha
escolha de carreira e eu comecei a
analisar por aí você professor porque
não mas é porque eu quero fazer o bem o
que é estar no lugar do outro para
pensar no outro aquilo que eu queria
fazer sendo médico
eu vou fazer sendo professor difícil é
tomar essa decisão em contar com os seus
pais depois você está anos tentando
fazer medicina não é mesmo tarefa nada
fácil
como continua a não ser tarefa fácil ser
professor hoje em dia ainda mais quando
eu contei para os meus pais e minha mãe
via e fala mas eduardo professor não
ganha bem e foi justamente neste momento
que eu vesti o escudo da coragem tomei a
decisão
eu não vou é sua professor eu vou ser um
professor com emoção você professor
diferente
eu vou ser professor para mudar a
história de muitas pessoas e eu acredito
que para ser professor
você precisa ser professor com atitude
com vontade com paixão com graça
o resultado disso tudo eu fiz amigos
muitos amigos em sala de aula
essa foto
é o retrato de um ex aluno meu de 2004
hoje médico cirurgião isso aí a foto do
meu casamento há quatro anos ele estava
no meu casamento e até hoje nós somos
grandes amigos
eu acredito que professor escola
universidade sirva pra isso é um
processo
cria-se uma ponte cria-se um caminho mas
é importante também perceber que isso
deve gerar um ciclo e neste ciclo a
gente retoma a ideia de que se a empatia
ea coragem ea vulnerabilidade foi
desenvolvida por professores
eles vão gerar isso nas instituições que
serão mais simpáticas corajosas e
vulneráveis
e assim nós teremos alunos formados por
essas instituições que terão os seus
valores formados pela empatia pela
coragem e pela vulnerabilidade
quando a gente olha então essa imagem
a gente vê que a empatia é a base de
tudo
eu acredito muito que as instituições de
ensino já faça hoje um trabalho
magnífico nas comunidades projetos
fantásticos mas uma coisa me intriga um
pouco porque não podemos colocar com
matéria eletiva o trabalho voluntário
para desenvolver no universitária a
empatia se colocar no lugar do outro
claro que isso respeitando as posições
de cada um sem nada ser imposto sem nada
ser obrigatório mas provavelmente assim
estaremos desenvolvendo na instituição
universidade
os valores da empatia da coragem da
vulnerabilidade e assim teríamos ações
mais completas por parte das próprias
instituições
os professores
e dos estudantes assim nós teríamos uma
educação cheia de graça eu deixo com
vocês as palavras de ricardo reis
heterónimo de fernando pessoa para ser
grande sem inteiro c todo em cada coisa
porém tudo que é no mínimo que faz assim
em cada lago a lua toda brilha porque
alta vive
senhoras e senhores muito obrigado
[Aplausos]